Hello, everyone.
Welcome to our session today.
Uh,
before I begin introducing my
presentation partner,
I would like to assess a little bit of
what your experience is with
regards to how you are enabling
your agentic solutions. So, would you
mind raising your hands if you're building
agents
that uh use
off the shelf foundation models,
querying API? Raise your hands.
Fantastic.
And then,
how many of you
are using or considering using
custom models
with your customize with your own data?
That's great.
Awesome.
So, today,
Um,
my colleague Laura Mullenex,
a senior
worldwide specialist solution architect,
uh, for Gen AI in SageMaker,
and myself,
Eric Pena, I'm a principal product manager
for Sagemaker AI.
We are going to
introduce you to how SageMaker
AI
is going to enable you with this
new capability we launched yesterday.
For customizing models so
that you can
Create better agentic applications
with increased performance.
And better results.
So, let me begin by
setting the stage
with a very important trend that you
might be aware of.
Um, a recent
study found that
The pace at which
Spend in AI
applications is growing, is twice
as much for those
applications that rely
on custom models.
You might argue that the in absolute
values, of course.
Um, querying directly, uh,
foundational model,
uh, an off the shelf foundation model API
is still bigger,
but the pace of growth is increasing.
The pace of growth is twice as much for
custom models.
So, let's understand why custom
custom models are going to be
more and more important.
First of all,
the obvious
uh reason, right?
If you want to have a model
that is
Uh, has better performance for a very
specific domain,
then
leveraging
even the most powerful of the shell
foundation model
might not give you the performance
and accuracy that you're looking for for your
specific application.
But not only that,
As your
applications and agents move from
the POC or the proof of concept
stage,
all the way to production implementation.
And then become a success,
scaling those workloads become.
More and more,
uh, less and less efficient
when you're using just a, a
mere
uh off the shelf foundation
model API.
There are
a little bit more niche reasons as well.
Let's say that you are operating in a
highly regulated industry,
and you have very strict
uh compliance and security requirements,
then leveraging
just an API for a foundation model
becomes less and less feasible.
But I think the most important point
here
is
They're just building a wrapper.
On top of one API
of a foundation model,
doesn't really give you a sustainable
differentiation from a product perspective.
Even if it's just
Providing value for your internal
customers,
or even more importantly, when you're
shipping value to external customers.
So as you can see,
customizing a model
provides this
increased value when it comes to
how
you will build those agentic solutions
that you will then
provide to your customers.
Let's put this in context.
Sorry,
excuse me.
How would you go about customizing
a model?
As you can imagine, this process is not always
straightforward.
The first is that you have
a plethora of customization techniques,
right? Um,
you can begin with the, with the
usual supervised on tuning,
but then if you want to get an extra
edge
when it comes to
additional performance, you might be.
Exploring additional techniques such as
preference optimization or reinforcement learning.
But that requires
Extra research time and effort.
It's not something that is easily available,
and you can iterate quickly.
The second part is also
You have to have some knowledge about the infrastructure
that your use case requires,
based on the customization technique at
hand. So,
How many GPUs will you use,
right?
It's always a factor of the dataset size,
the customization technique,
so it's always a a a a trial
and error iteration
workflow.
That can take a lot of time for you
to fulfill.
Then, what we have found
when talking to customers,
many of them have a very good
understanding
of what the business use case is.
They understand what they want to accomplish,
but then moving from that particular
definition.
Onto a model customization
specification,
it's much more complex,
right? How do we move from a business use
case description to an actual model customization,
that involves,
right? The data set that you are going to use,
the model choice,
and the customization technique.
And finally,
you have to be able to do this at scale,
right? The very nature
of AI and agentic
solution building
relies on you
quickly iterating on multiple
experiments.
This is not just,
let's try this,
and this will be the solution that ends
up being used.
The more you can
do in order to get
more experiments running,
the better you'll be able to achieve
the accuracy and performance goals.
That you want to get to,
in order to make
your use case feasible and
a success.
So, in order for us to
show you how we are going to enable
you
with the tools to tackle
these challenges,
let's put this in the
end to end workflow
for model customization.
And then we will see how we are addressing
each step of the
workflow.
As you can see,
you begin by defining goals.
And evaluation criteria.
What is it exactly that you want to achieve?
Then,
you gather your data,
you craft your data sets,
based on what you can get,
enhancing the data that you have,
or even generating synthetic data.
In order to enable your use cases.
Then
It's the process of customizing the
model itself,
right? How can you get
to in the right technique, choosing
the right model.
And
creating that cost model and then
begin assessing
based on the evaluation criteria that you
have defined.
In the previous step.
2, whether you get to that.
And result that you are seeking to
achieve. Then
it's rinse and repeat, right? This is not
something that you do once.
It's something that you have to continually
experiment to try to find
that combination.
Of data
and model
that makes
your application or your agent a
success.
Finally,
deploying your model,
roll out to production.
And begin reaping the benefits of
this new custom model.
Let's go one by one then.
How are we help are going,
how are we going to help you define
your goals and arrive
to a a a better
Um, use case specification.
Yesterday we launched the
preview of our SageMaker
AI model customization agent.
The model customization agent,
what it does.
Is
It will take
your use case definition
in natural language.
It will create.
Uh, and it will, it will go back and forth
with you to define exactly what
the use case is,
and what evaluation criteria is the
best to achieve the goals
that you have set out to achieve
in your use case definition.
And finally,
It will lay out that use
case specification
for you to approve
and continue forward.
This might eventually,
you know, end up
customizing a model,
if you, if you choose to move forward with with
the agent as well.
So, this is the UI
of SageMaker AI Sage Maker
Studio.
When you go to the new
models page, you will see that
the models that are supporting this new
customization capability
will have the customized button,
and you have three options there.
The one that is labeled in preview,
will enable you to launch a
conversation with the agent.
You can also begin the conversation
without selecting a model,
in which case you will have an opportunity
to to go back and forth with the
agent and then choose one.
So, here's the uh
UI of the agent.
The agent
will go into a conversation
with you
to define exactly what you're seeking.
Once
It has defined,
once you have laid out
exactly what you want to achieve,
the agent will
Suggest
additional information for your use
case, and then
provide with options for you to choose
um with regards to the model that you
can use and the customization technique.
Finally,
it will lay out
the list of success criteria
that you can approve or maybe
go and edit, right? Maybe you see
that You want to add,
tweak,
remove.
Some of the success criteria you're not satisfied,
you can continue iterating with the agent
until you're satisfied with the success criteria
and approve it, and then you move forward.
So that is the way, this gentic
back and forth, in which we're making it
easier for you
to be able to move quickly
from just a raw business use case
into
an actual model customization.
Specification.
Then The most
important piece in model customization, which is
Dataset gathering and enhancement
and curation.
This agent will be able
to
request you to provide some examples
or additional context with regards to
the data that you want to provide,
and then
generate data that matches
that
those examples that you have provided.
But it will not only provide
the synthetic data,
it will also analyze it
based on a set of criteria
that include responsible AI
controls.
So that you are aware.
Uh, and, and are cautious about
the data that you are using, to avoid bias,
to avoid,
you know, harmful content.
That data generation will
require you to choose any underlying
compute. Is it serverless,
end to end.
And so, here's a a a a
sample of this back and forth,
the agent tells you
that he's ready to begin gathering data.
And then
You provide those examples.
And then the agent.
Shares with you
the specification of your data
set. Once
generation. Uh,
you decide exactly how many,
how many, uh, features you are going
to be using or you want the agent to generate,
uh, additional configuration items
such as the S3 bucket you want the, the
data file to reside on.
And you can also provide a history bucket
of contextual data you want to have
the agent use as a reference to
generate those data.
You choose the number of rows,
the bucket,
and once generation is complete.
You can see the quality of your data,
based on what I was just describing, right?
Your statistics, your AI
quality metrics, including responsible
AI. Um
Criteria.
But I know
many of you.
are, are even.
More prone to do things yourself.
Maybe you already have a dataset,
maybe you like
to use your own data as opposed to just
relying on an agent.
That's also something that we anticipated
customers will prefer to
default,
and then as a consequence, we have
created the means by which you can
upload or create your
data sets.
And then use them in any
customization job that you would like
to run in the platform.
So
Here in Decision-Maker Studio
UI.
You have
The assets section
on the left.
And
the first item is, of course, datasets.
You can create a data set.
And then
You will get
to a form where you can
name your data set and upload your file,
or you can also provide an
an estuary bucket.
Uh, if you have already uploaded your data
set to S3.
When, in a moment, we are going to continue
um talking about
um what the technique, what the techniques
are going to be. One of, uh,
one of which is really important, and I
know that you you might have already been
uh doing some research on it, reinforcement learning
is becoming more and more important as a
as a means to do model customization
for model alignment, right?
And so,
One of the things that we consider is
what other assets you
may also want to build uh
to upload and have ready for any
job that may come after, after that.
So
We also created.
The evaluator asset.
The evaluator asset has
two types, one is a reward
function. Which is the
code that you would
create for
Let's say reinforcement learning with verifiable
rewards, right?
You just create it once and then
you can use it in any model customization
job that you want to
run. Uh,
the UI will provide you with guidance
as to what the code should
look like from a format standpoint.
Uh, and
under the hood, it will be created as a lambda
function. As you can
see,
you can go to lambda as well,
create your reward function in lambda, and
just, and then just pull the lambda R
into the UI in order to create
that evaluator
that you can reference.
The other is.
How about reinforcement learning with
AI feedback?
In that case,
you may be needing to create
prompts for your reward models.
Here you can create those ones and then
use them as you please
in the UI.
In a similar manner,
you choose the reward prompt,
and you're guided to the format that you
can use, so that you can create those
reward prompts and use them on your
model customization.
Uh, experiments.
As always, you can do this very
simple,
very simply, if you want to use
a code first approach, right? We
have updated our Python SDK
to include the constructs
that will enable you to create
these assets for model customization.
I know many of you might be, you know, more
comfortable using code first,
so we are making it easier for you as
well in that arena.
OK, so
How about customizing the models?
One of the things that I mentioned was
the infrastructure configuration
complexity, right?
We've talked about this, you need to know
what
what GPU I'm going to be using or
I need to use,
how many of these accelerators are
required to run these jobs?
Well, we are abstracting that
con that configuration complexity
from the process so that you can focus
on
what is important for you.
Which is creating
experiments
that walk towards
your overall performance goals.
That's why we launched yesterday serverless
reinforcement learning.
In other words, you will be able to launch
reinforcement learning jobs without
needing to configure any GPU
configuration or the number of nodes.
As you can see,
the UI will also have, and that's the 2nd,
the the the the first option there, customize
with UI.
If you know what you wanna do,
you just click customize with UI.
And that will take you to a very simple form
where you choose your customization
technique. In this case, let's say that it's
reinforcement learning with AI feedback.
That will allow you to choose a reward model.
In this case we're using Bedrock under
the Hoio. This will be using Bedrock
APIs and your calling
and your,
your after the rollout phase, reward
is being, is, is using this
reward model and Bedrock
to provide rewards and then continue the
training loop.
Of course, the second piece is
what prompt you are going to use for the reward model.
And then you can, you can choose custom,
and in that case, what you're going to do is choose
the evaluator that you created in the other
section that I showed earlier,
or you can also provide the code yourself.
Uh, in this interface, and then create
that evaluator at the same time.
Of course, you can tweak some
hyperparametters
that we are exposing. This is not, as
you may already have noticed,
this is not an exhaustive list,
what This
is,
in essence,
Um, a very, what we
are, we have heard customers
that is the set of hyperparameterss
that they normally tweak the most,
but we would love to hear from you,
which additional ones would you think
would be useful to have
as part of the ones that you can tweak immediately
in the form.
We have advanced configuration if you want
to go deeper,
and some additional configurations such as
the ML flow
app. That we are going to use. I'm
going to talk about ML flow in a minute.
So, once you click submit,
this will land you on the training job
details page,
which will show you immediately
the training.
Metrics,
so that you can stop the job if it's trending
wrong.
Uh, you can check and troubleshoot using the log
stack. You can also
gain access to the artifacts tab
to see
where your model artifacts are going to be
stored, etc.
But Everything,
as you can see, is revolving around
the single concept, which is the most
important piece here, which is
the custom model. The custom model
is the start of the show,
and as such,
we have, we have a button up
there that you can use to go
to the,
to the actual custom model details
page. Once the job has run,
you can go to the custom model details page,
so you can see exactly
Everything about that customer.
The lineage, where you can track
which dataset was used for training,
and you can also trigger additional actions
such as continued customization.
You can, for instance, run an uh
an uh reinforcement fine-tuning job after
running a supervised fine tuning
and continue improving your performance.
You can also
Do this in code.
So we have
the uh
new SDK classes
for you to launch this serverless
training jobs
from your code.
It can be a notebook,
it can be a Python file, etc.
This is an example of one of the classes that we
have created.
What you do next is evaluate your
model, obviously. If you want to have another
data set to assess whether
you are achieving your performance,
you can run evaluation of models
using
You can use your, you know, regular benchmarks,
although
I know
all of you know that
that might not be as useful if
you're looking for a specific use case.
So you can uh create your own custom
metrics.
You remember about the evaluators? You can
use evaluators to create more custom metrics
that can be used here for evaluation as well.
You can also leverage prompts
for LLM as a judge
evaluation.
At the end of each evaluation, you will have
visual scorecards that show you,
this is how you evaluate, this is the button.
And you can check
The evaluation job configuration,
when you create or choose
an LLM as a judge.
Uh, option,
and you can create your prompt from a template
in order to run that evaluation.
And then
How do we make this efficient, an efficient
workflow, so you can do it at multiple
times.
Well, we're
integrating,
this is the iteration part,
we're integrating with ML flow. We
launched this year as well
serverlessML flow,
server less ML flow.
Uh, you don't have to configure or pay
anything else.
Serverless, a serverless ML flow app will
be created for you, and immediately
begin logging
to the, to the app
as you run experiments.
No additional cost.
As you can see,
there's this button that says view
metrics details in MFFlow.
You click it and then you immediately launch
a new tab in your browser with the
MFFlow interface that you know and love.
Finally,
Once you have conducted your experiments,
now you have
a uh a model that you are satisfied
with, you can deploy it.
So, let's see how we deployment easier.
Sage Maker AI now
enables you to either launch
or deploy your custom model
to Sage Maker AI inference endpoints,
or Bedrock
as well. So you can go,
select your option and uh
Lauren is going to show you how exactly it is
done. You can
launch and and create a model
that you can then query through Bedrock APIs.
Both are totally possible
and you can do that from the UI.
All right.
So,
This is kind of a whiz, a very
quick
pass through all the experience.
I think now it's time for Lauren
to come and
show you exactly how this looks like.
OK,
Before I show everyone what the new model customization
UI looks like,
um, with Stage on StageMaker AI,
let me set some context.
So, as Eric just mentioned,
the model customization process, it's
often a month-long process.
You have to spend time
researching what model to use
and what fine
fine tuning techniques should you choose,
as well as coordinating with your platform team
for compute access.
Then you spend time experimenting with
different approaches and optimizations.
The new model customization features that we
have with StageMaker AI,
they help remove friction from this process.
The use case I'm about to demonstrate is for
tool calling.
So what exactly is tool calling?
Tool calling enables models to
interact with external systems.
So you can do API calling, you can query
a database,
um, or you can also execute functions.
So, this is what makes agents,
uh, very useful,
um, in production-ready environments.
Now,
base foundation models are often not
production ready for tool calling.
They hallucinate tools that don't
exist. They
fail to uh call
tools that are readily available and they also
execute on incomplete information.
And this is where model customization can help with
this process.
So I'm about to show you how in less
than an hour you can use the new model customization
UI um on StageMaker
Studio
to select a model,
evaluate its performance, fine tune it
first, of course, evaluate its performance
and then deploy it.
So let's get started.
Here I am in Sagemaker's studio, so
I'm navigated to the model section.
You can see here that we have over 1000
models
that we foundation models that we've vetted.
We've also provided hundreds of fine
tuning recipes for them.
For this use case, I'm going to choose
the Queen 2.57 beat
instruct model.
It's a good choice for tool calling
because it has excellent instruction
following capabilities and it has good
performance for its size.
So here, you can see that you can customize
a model with an AI agent that's in preview that
Eric just went over. I'm gonna specifically
walk through
the uh customize with the UI
capability in SageMaker Studio.
So all I do is click this.
And you can see that we have this template
uh for customizing Queen 2.57B
instruct.
There are different customization techniques
you can choose.
So supervised fine tuning,
direct preference optimization,
as well as reinforcement, um,
learning techniques.
Uh, so, we have reinforcement learning with
verifiable rewards or LRVR
or reinforcement learning from AI feedback,
RLAIF.
I'm going to walk through reinforcement
learning with verifiable rewards.
What exactly is RLVR?
Well,
um, we just talked about how
models, base foundation models often struggle
with tool calling precision.
So, we need to find a way
to improve the exact correctness of the
outputs.
So, with RLVR
for each prompt, we generate
multiple different responses.
And then we have what's called a custom reward function,
and that reward function then
verifies if each response is
correct. This enables the model
to learn
and that increases the probability
of the correct outputs
relative to the incorrect ones.
This also uses what's called
group relative policy optimization
or GRPO. So
for each prompt,
those multiple responses are generated. We're
gonna have 8 in this case.
They're in a group, and they're ranked or
scored
by correctness here.
So that's what I'll be showcasing.
So if I choose RLVR,
You'll see that I have the option
to either use a built-in reward function,
we have exact match or code execution
math answers, but in this case,
I really want to, you know, define
what good looks like for my use case exactly.
So I'm going to use a custom reward function.
And so what this is, I'm gonna navigate
to our evaluators page,
and here I can create a ward
function or a reward prompt.
You can see that I've created one earlier,
and all it is is Python code that
I have.
Uh, you can also, you know, upload your, your lambda
function as well. See if I can zoom in.
Um, but essentially,
uh, this reward function that we're gonna
use, it has, it's going to extract
the tool calls from the model's
responses and compare it to our
ground truth.
And it's in a three-tier scoring system.
So what that means here is it's gonna
give these different scores here in the middle. So
one
is a perfect match, which means it's
calling the right function and the right parameters.
0.5 is a partial match,
so that's the right function but the wrong parameters,
and 0 is wrong match
or it's a missing tool call.
Now, our reward function handles an
important edge use case.
What that means is sometimes
it's correct to not do a tool
call. For example,
if you have a user who asks
the model what's the weather like,
but they don't specify a location,
then the model should respond and ask for clarification
instead of providing a bad API call.
So this reward function
recognizes and actually reinforces that behavior.
Right. So now I'm gonna navigate back to
my
page for my training setup
and I'm gonna choose that reward function that I already
set up.
And then you have the option here to, you know, upload
a data set, have one that's already in S3,
which I already do.
So I'm going to select this existing training data
set that I have.
And this contains 1500
tool calling,
uh, samples. So it's a data set
that's derived from the Nvidia's when to call.
And it has
examples of three different types of behavior.
So it either executes a tool
call when you have sufficient information,
it clarifies when there's missing parameters,
or it refuses the response
to provide a response when there's harmful
information, for example, which I'll show at the very end.
You can also see that there's an option to provide
your validation data set.
Um, if you do not provide one,
StageMaker AI will automatically
split your training data set.
So you'll have your validation data,
um, metrics that are already provided, um,
for you during training.
And what this enables is
that the model behavior, you know, can
improve by,
um, not seeing this actual, you know, validation
examples, so it just doesn't learn on the training examples
as well.
Here's where we set our output, um,
you know, artifact, model artifacts location at S3.
Here's the hyperparameterss uh that
we can configure. So for batch size,
I'll leave this at 128. That sounds OK
for the size of the model
and uh for the amount of data
records that I have.
Update the learning rates and I'll have this
passed through the data 3 times.
Also, we have rollouts here that's set to 8.
So that's essentially that we're generating 8
responses for each prompt.
Also,
we are doing experiment tracking
with our new Cerber-less ML
flow. So I've already created a Cerber-less
MLflow app, so you don't have to worry about
any infrastructure provisioning there in MLflow,
brand new capability we launched.
And ML flow automatically tracks
all our training metrics.
So that includes our
uh loss values, um,
as well as our reward scores in this instance
and hyperparametters.
So that way you can compare your training runs
and then also reproduce results.
Now we also have some, of course,
security, top of mind here, AWS so
you can have this run in a private BBC
for example, and then have encryption
with, uh, you know, KMS keys for
uh storage as well.
So, let's just talk about what happens next.
Uh, you may have noticed that I don't have
to worry about any training configuration
set up here.
So, as Eric just mentioned,
one of the key
features that we just launched is
serverless training.
So
in fine tuning, you often have to provision
GPU clusters. You need to manage
distributed training strategies,
and you have to, um, yeah,
configure communication between GPUs
as well as, um,
handling the fault tolerance and checkpointing.
So that's often weeks of infrastructure
work before you can even get started.
So we've
removed that infrastructure complexity here, so you
don't have to worry about that all of this runs completely serverless.
So let me, everything looks good here. I'm ready to submit
my training job, my fine tuning
job. So this will take about
30 minutes to complete.
So let me navigate to a training run that I've already
completed to show you the results.
So we'll see here, this took about
a little over 30 minutes to complete on our 1500
samples.
And I have my um training metrics
that are loading right here that have
already been populated that you can also view in
serverless ML flow.
The main metric that I wanna focus on,
the key one, is the train reward statistics.
So what that means here is this is the model's
reward score,
or it's um how often
the right tool was called with the right parameters.
So it started off here at
about only 25% it was
able to make the right tool calls. The
base model was.
So during the 30 plus
minutes of training,
we hit
0.67 or are now able to
generate 67% of the time
the right tool calls.
So we, you know, essentially doubled our
performance just in 30 minutes,
um, doing fine tuning on this model.
So this looks, you know, pretty good to me
so far. So,
what should we do now is that we need to evaluate
on a held
out, uh, test data set
so that we can measure the model's real-world
performance,
um, on examples it's never seen before.
So we're able to do that as well with the new model
customization features.
Here we go to our custom model.
And then we're able to evaluate
it. Um, that's what I'll be doing.
You can also continue on, uh,
customization. So
perhaps you wanna adjust the hyperparametters. 67%
of, you know, tool calls isn't the
right metric you're looking for. You can also train
with a different technique as well.
So we're gonna move on to evaluation.
Eric just went over that there's a lot of different evaluation
types
for ROVR in this use case,
it makes sense to have a
custom uh reward function like we've been
using. So I'm
going to choose the custom reward function.
I'm gonna use the exact same one
and I'm gonna compare it with the base model too
in our evaluation runs.
I want to use the same reward function because
that's evaluating then this the
model on the same exact specific criteria
that we set for training.
So I picked that reward function.
And I've already uploaded a, you
know, similar data set for evaluation
with the similar behaviors that I talked
about earlier, so execute
or clarify or refuse.
This has 300 samples, so
definitely, you know, smaller for evaluation.
And here are the advanced configuration
uh parameters I need to sets.
This is just the context window.
So I'll have that at 2046,
and the max new tokens is just
the tool calls responses.
So
I'll set that tokens of 512.
I'll leave the temperature in the top K and the top
P, uh, the same.
And then I'll keep this in a,
that's the default as well.
So I'll submit that.
And this will take about
10 minutes
to actually run the evaluation
uh jobs
um on StageMaker
and we'll compare the base model
to the custom model.
So let me navigate to an already completed
um run here.
Let's take a look first at the lineage just to show you that
this is also available, which is very helpful
then, um, so you can do governance
and determine like where is your actual, you know, data
coming from, what have you been doing, you can see your,
your pipeline and then, um, you know,
could deploy this to production as well. So this
is all available, uh, here.
You also have logs that you could take a look at
to determine what the model's doing.
Maybe you need to do like some early stopping.
And then we have the evaluation
metrics that are already um.
Loaded for you here as well. These
are also available in ML flow
um by default.
So the main metrics that
I think are important to highlight
are the tool call reward.
So you can see that the base model,
it's at 0.35 and we were able to
increase that by 20 points
to 0.55.
So what does this actually mean? Is
that the model is making
the right decision either to
execute,
um, on to execute a tool,
uh, or clarify on,
you know, missing parameter if there's missing parameters
or refuse the request.
So we're able to do that now 55%
of the time.
And all we had to do was this took about,
you know, 40 minutes to do training and evaluation,
which is often,
you know, a multi-month process just to set this up.
The next metric that
I think is important is the F1
score
uh quasi
quasi.
So the base score you can see here is about
46%
and the custom score, so
our fine-tuned model, is now,
uh,
the results are 64.6%.
So this actually measures the output
quality.
What that means is that the model generate
the right function name.
The correct parameters and the
proper JSON formatting. So it's essentially
2/3 at a time.
The outputs are functionally correct here.
You can also view the full evaluation
results um in ML flow. There's a lot
more metrics you can take a look at.
So I can compare
the different.
Um,
training runs I had here.
So all I have to do is check those and then click compare
and then you can see here's our base model on the
left and our actually I probably just
clicked the wrong ones, but the custom model on
the right and you'll be able to see all the different metrics
and compare them. So there's more in here
that are, you know, system metrics and so forth.
OK, so now our evaluation,
you know, looks pretty good to me, and we're ready
to deploy this model and test it,
um, you know, for inference on some
requests that we have.
I have the option
to deploy
um on Bedrock
or
on StageMakker. So let's do
StageMaker for real-time inference. I'm
going to create a new endpoint.
And here I just
type in the endpoint name and by default
it's recommending an MLGXG6
12X large instance.
I can update that, um, you know,
depending on your needs
and you also have some options as far as updating
the, uh, you know, instance count, the max instance
count. There's also some auto-scaling that you can set as
well. If you notice here,
I don't have to
build an inference container or write any serving
codes. So we've extracted that away for you, so
it's very easy to deploy here.
So I'll just click deploy.
And this will take about 10 minutes
to provision that real-time
inference end point and stage maker.
So let me navigate to an endpoint that's
already up.
You can see that we have our base model and our
Laura adapter, so that's our, you know, pre-trained
weights combined with our learned adaptation.
And here we also have a
playground that you can test the
model's, you know,
responses.
So I'm gonna update this to a single prompt
mode and then here you can see
that we have a system prompt.
So this is uh very important for
uh tool calling.
Um,
because here you're able to define
the tools that are available
as well as,
um, so define the tools that are available as
well as the expected JSON, uh,
outputs,
and this also includes then our
three behaviors that we trained on.
So that would be the execute, clarify,
or refuse. So let's test out some
examples here to see what this looks like in action.
We also have some other metrics that we can add that
we can um update, um, or
sorry, some other parameters we can update.
So we have those output tokens such as
the the model's response
and as well as the randomness on diversity.
I want to keep the temperature pretty low
because I want these tool calls to be deterministic
and not be very creative. Top P looks
good to me as well.
And then I just enter my prompt here in the bottom.
So, first, I'll start with a
tool call, um, that should execute.
So I'll enter in
what is the stock price.
For Amazon.
And I can run that
And here it's actually gonna generate that tool call like
we expected. And then it could also, you
know, um, do an external API
call and we'll get the current stock price for Amazon.
So that's exactly what they expect the model
to do.
So that's that perfect match,
um, as well where it's the right,
uh, function and the right parameters.
OK.
Now let's do an example where the model
should ask to clarify.
So, you know, I asked, I mentioned
earlier like what's the weather like?
Well, right now,
you know, the model has no idea where I am. There's no like geolocation
enabled, so it's asking
for clarification.
So it's asking me,
could I please specify the city that I'm interested in.
So you know I could add that in it should,
um, you know, respond.
Now let's enter in a harmful
request that the model should refuse.
So,
How do I hack into an email
address? So,
just because, so since we fine tune our model, now
it's actually responding and saying that it can't assist
with hacking or any illegal activities. So
please provide a legitimate request for
assistance,
which is exactly what we want the model
to respond with.
So, results look pretty good to me. So
looks like this, this may be ready for production
or at least you can test this more
um in you know in your QA environment
and then determine um if this works
for your use case.
OK, so let's just recap
what we did.
We were able to use the new
model customization UI
um in Stage Maker Studio.
And we used RLVR
and fine-tuned with the custom reward
function. With
serverless infrastructure, so we didn't have to set up any
of that training, so we removed all the infrastructure
complexities there.
We were able to evaluate the model's
performance with a custom reward function.
You could also use more deterministic benchmarks
as well as LLM as a judge, for
example, on Bedrock,
and we were able to deploy the model
for real-time inference. And we were able
to do that in, you know, less
than. Uh, you know, all
less than an hour.
So instead of navigating the,
you know, model complexities that
often take months, you can really
define your use case
and, and focus on that.
You're able to iterate
in, you know, hours instead of weeks
or months with the new model customization features in StageMaker
AI. So I hope that you
try it out today
and start experimenting with your own use cases.
So thank you and let us know if you have any
questions. So
Thank you all, and please don't forget to
fill out the survey.
That's very important for us,
and we are happy to answer any questions if
you want to
stick around and chat with us. Thank you all.